bonjour bonjour vous êtes le seigneur de
la valette dont je suis un la valette
mais je me suis plus jamais été je suis
pas un seigneur où va t on chez nous
n'est pas un seigneur c'est un mot qui
s'en s'ont son fagots son vieux temps
non je suis je suis un héritier c'est
très lourd vers un héritier eric et de
quilles héritier non pas des grands noms
qui ont pu habiter cette maison-là
posséder méritée d'un grand père mon
grand père qui le dr maurice de fleury
de laquelle une médecine s'il vous plaît
grand neurologue du début de ce siècle
amie de grands écrivains et de grands
poètes et qui a décidé un jour de retour
reprendre contact avec le pays de ses
propres ancêtres qui était cette région
de du bas poitou de la charente
il a trouvé ici l'acheter à la commune
en 1911 pour 5000 francs de l'époque
ce qui fait un peu plus qu'aujourd'hui
enfin c'était il a acheté une ruine il y
avait des arbres qui poussent sur ce qui
m'attend à salon il ya un marchand de
chèvre qui faisait sondés sont d'élevage
dans dance irvine et il a eu à coeur de
transmettre rendre vie à cette maison
comment tenez vous cette ruine c'est
très difficile parce que c'est plus la
mesure d'un homme d'un propriétaire
maintenant c'est à la mesure d'une
communauté mon frère et moi nous serrons
les coudes pour essayer de te garder
cette maison et d'avoir nous aussi des
héritiers pour leur transmettre le
château de villebois lavalette
c'est à dire que vous tournez le dos au
château finalement sont les hausses at
on lui dit lui dit adieu pour aller
gagner de quoi le mérite et le seul
château modernes que nous connaissions
ici c'est le vote c'est-à-dire un
château qui est ouvert par l'histoire à
tous les vents parler les dégâts de
l'histoire mais pas par l'évolution des
moeurs et oui s'il n'y a pas là une
porte ne confirme jamais il n'y a pas de
serrure n'ya pas de clé on entre et puis
on visite les milliardième qui fait
visiter n'a pas de tarif la porte prix
en entrée puis voilà on est on est on
est chez soi
cadets l'ombre la plus illustre de ce
château dans l'histoire c'est le duc
d'epernon qui était d'epernon qui fut
une sorte de zorro d'errol flynn
personnage bagarreur insolente de
mauvaise foi à caractère exécrable sous
souris trois ils étaient un million
d'euros je vais vous dire si le corps et
les filles ce zorro l'annoncé pas ce
moment-là n'en parlons pas et puis plus
tard si ces mariés bien sûr il va là
reçu le jeune louis xiii qui lui venait
de se marier à bordeaux mais vous passez
un peu rapidement sur un épisode de sa
vie il était dans le carrosse de d'henri
iv quand henri iv a reçu le couteau dont
on dit que l'on était tout à côté comme
ont depuis lors été d un petit peu dans
le coup du complot c'est possible un
homme de 114 ravaillac était plus quoi
elle reste du pays et l'ombre de
d'epernon ne vous tracasse jamais
vous ne rencontrez pas si je les
rencontre et bien sûr j'ai rencontré lui
même obsédé pendant plusieurs semaines
me suis trouvé à la fois la valette et
epernon je conseillais est un terreau
les chatons de son frère le maréchal
arrêté dans son camp et déférées à des
juges aux gens je sais pas car pour
succéder au d'epernon bernard y fait
avoir des reins solides et theater à
toute épreuve
vous êtes le troisième représentant des
de fleury installé dans le château de la
valette
est-ce que vous pouvez affirmer qu'il ya
le même esprit les mêmes formes j'allais
dire et la même continuité enfin dans
votre démarche
je pense mon grand père grand médecin la
table et de travail d'écriture il
écrivait beaucoup donner des conférences
il avait des congrès et avait besoin de
s'isoler une fois par an au moins et de
retrouver lui-même de retrouver sa
propre sensibilité sa propre
personnalité
loin de la ville tuant des attentes
et c'est ici qu'ils jettent ils venaient
qu'il organisait en fins la vie telle
qu'elle était pour lui ça son véritable
équilibre mais c'était avec sa famille
avec les gens du village qu'il soignait
souvent eh bien moi j'ai l'impression
que je payais aux mêmes besoins la même
nécessité de se retremper dans dans ce
pays
albert dans une pièce à la chronique
comment peut-on ne pas aimer la levée
quand on digère bien moi je digère bien
et j'aime à digérer en présence de ma
femme adorée c'est vrai de ma mère
infiniment respecté de mon petit-fils
thomas 6 juin de ma fille ma fille
cadette préféré et son prochain lardons
et de son mari mon gendre avait peu
qu'elle contrairement à la légende je
m'entends merveilleusement à ce moment
là dans la pièce entre une dame à qui je
dis et d'où sortez vous
vous elle me répond moi je suis la bonne
voyez en 1980 à villebois-lavalette ya
plus de bonnes thomas tourner le dos à
la postérité
thomas n'est pas 4 et cabourg thomas est
beaucoup plus intéressés par son grand
père que par l'avenir tabassé le premier
en date de mes petits enfants
le futur la valette où la valeur il
s'appellera pas il ne s'appelle pas la
valette il s'appellera jamais le futur
seigneur de la valette peut-être bien
peut-être bien le voilà qui nous quitte
et quel enfant avez vous été vous
bernard angers tgs que c'est de la
chance ou pas de chance que je peux
vis-à-vis des auteurs de biographies
émouvante je n'ai pas la chance d'avoir
été un enfant martyr j'avais pas de
parents qui buvait qui se battait devant
moi c'est terrible normal je ne peux pas
écrire un livre bouleversant dont on
tirera feuilleton télévisé affaires
sangloter dans les chaumières
c'est pas du tout c'est un handicap très
vous et eu des lacunes dans le cadre de
cet explosif nous faisons autour de
votre modeste personne a le moindre au
drame dans le drame non et puis la
lâcheté chose d'avoir un château c'est
scandaleux
il ya des situations comme ça sur
lesquelles une commune pas trop insisté
mais même dans d enfance heureuse il ya
des maladies il ya des scarlatine il ya
des rougeoles ya des orages
oui parce que toutes les fenêtres on
voit les orages de tous les côtés et
c'est appréciable c'est beau alors ce
cas sous les draps on se cache pas sous
les draps rhône où on nous fait lever et
on nous montre le spectacle et vous
n'avez pas peur et on n'a pas peur parce
que le mot peur vis-à-vis de mes enfants
en tout cas et mais enfin les petits
enfants n'emploie pas le mot peur comme
ça entre le mot et la chose
il n'y a pas de lien c'est parce que
c'est un peu puisqu'on ne connaît pas le
mot et quand le grand duc dans le
grenier là-haut marche la nuit esprits
mais pas peur et bien non on entendait
le grand duc
on entendait le fantôme nous on a
franchi c'est toujours les gens qui
venaient ici en leur disant si vous
entendez des pas dans le grenier ce
n'est pas un fantôme
c'est un grand duc c'est à dire une
grosse souhaite qu'ils marchent quand le
grand duc un parent très noble et dans
les greniers
il a beaucoup d'alluré vous aidant dans
le cas de votre enfance je crois que la
seule solution c'est de retourner à la
fontaine c'est à dire à la source
et puisque le grand duc ne vous fait pas
peur alors ensemble ont retrouvé le
corbeau et le renard peut-être à l'école
de villebois-lavalette que je connais
bien
bonjour fabrice est ce que tu te
souviens que mois d'avril je suis venu
dans sa classe avec ton professeur ton
maître monsieur le dernier qui lui avait
demandé de venir dans la classe pour
parler du métier d'acteur sous des airs
y avait demandé de vous réciter une
fable de la fontaine
tu te souviennes est des femmes qu'on
avait lu il y avait je n'avais pas 2,6
mais quel est ce que tu te souviens
lesquels ça fait plusieurs mois
maintenant leurs nerfs oui
et voilà c'est ça alors je vous avais
précités ces deux femmes un oui est ce
que tu es tu sais maintenant tu as
appris le corbeau d'honneur oui tu l'as
pris tu veux me le dire aujourd'hui
qu'elle tenait dans son baquet maître
renard par l'odeur des chiens witek un
peu pressés et bonjour monsieur du
corbeau que vous êtes jolie que vous me
semblez beau sortir tu entres en
remettre à votre plumage des hôtes de
ces bois à c'est un mot difficile est
pas courant des hôtes de ces bois et
qu'est ce que vous avez dit après
rappelle toi tu avais parlé de mon père
qui m'avait appris quand j'étais petit
que j'avais 7 ans comme toi le corbeau
et le renard mais l enfant à l'envers
oui notre corps chez m corsé rires ne
dit rien de bien mettre en corse et sur
un arbre perbos tenait dans son un
maître rocher par l'odeur
allez l'art lui gages à peu près ce
fabrice c'est tuer qui je téléphone à je
t'aime fun à pierre tchernia avec qui
j'étais au lycée
autrefois et qui connaît le corbeau et
le renard en a beaucoup
moi je lai à peu près oublier à temps we
would situé au dessus c'est bien ça à
l'aube pierre quercy bernard allô allô
allô allô c'est bernard ça à l'eau
bernard alaux assez bernard la valette
mais j'entends très mal il n'entend pas
il m'entend pas alors que ses bêtes
j'avais pu arriver à me rappeler la
phrase la femme jusqu'au bout un pignouf
attend qu'ils ont eu les numéros
toujours qu'est ce que c'était dans ce
poème
c'était une fable de la fontaine en
argot qu'on avait apprise et qui nous
amusent est tellement c'est le corbeau
et le renard caire alors un pignouf de
korbach sur un arbre planqué pincer dans
la fiole un coup l'embarras qu'est un
mas de goupil qu'avec des clous comme
bektas lui tient à peu près ce tract ans
n'a ensuite plus la suite berne à
molsheim au labo canaris main ce que tu
n'aies goc tout à fait vrai de vrai
comme un mec là aussi tu pousse sa
gueulante aussi bien que technip et tlm
hector l'arbre et métaux du quartier à
l'eau claire
alors obama à l'eau les réveils
m'attends pas assez bon le couple ils
étaient bien mario lui fils sont coulant
barakeh dans la fiole enlever ces peser
10 legoupil dès l'aube et adopté hier ça
marche toujours quoi tu m'entends je
l'entends hague est loin tant pis
moralité méfie-toi les mectons quitte la
faune aller ce tome et qui sans voile
que le temps des jo bats par la pomme
pierre alaux bernard allô allô oui
doigté fin de vie de bois laval est
d'ailleurs villebois-lavalette corps
quand j'avais été que il voulait faire
du théâtre et puis que moi j'avais envie
aussi de faire du spectacle
je lui avais conseillé de prendre ça
comme pseudonyme jeudi du doigt table
bernard la valette et puis moi pierre
villebois serait très bien alors
t'appeler la valette moi je me suis et
reste sur st pierre tchernia à l'eau
bernard non bon moi je n'aurai pas le
rappellera un de ces jours on n'a pas
fini de se voir la vie et donc j'espère
rien à faire c'est idiot comme ça
tiendra pas participer à cette émission
sénat c'est agaçant
le téléphone abritent un tiers dernière
c'est la grande époque du lycée pasteur
mais le lycée pasteur ont réussi à en
sortir brillamment ou bruyamment le baco
le bachot chose c'est déjà pas mal le
bachot rusant 13% mention mais enfin le
macho voilà élan débouche sur valu la
vie universitaire là il ya des choix à
faire
où va-t-on ah non pas du côté de la rue
saint-guillaume pour sciences po on va
du côté de la rue saint-jacques pour le
droit on va aussi en plein coeur du
quartier latin pour licence d'italiens
ou conduit la licence italien en italie
et ce qu'elle prêtait qu'un voyage
d'étudiants un d'études ou d'étudiants
au d'étudiants d'étudiants pour visiter
rome boulistes et naples capri être
reçus par le cndd listé quelques abris
etc et capoue et on ramène quoi d une
thèse une langue une des chansons les
gens sont des chansons je suis parti
pour l'italie
[Musique]
et oui je suis perdue par l'italie
est ce que j'ai fait en me disant
l'occurrence il faut changer le petit
ami à l'étranger il faut faire mieux si
j'avais su turlututu seraient pas partis
soient pas caucus était une chanson de
chansonniers oui il vaut mieux que la
famille ne l'ait pas entendu à l'époque
et le droit à des voussures quoi et bien
sûr le caveau du carca mousse leurs
caveaux le karkabou s'assure une
distension du tout pour ses dons non sur
le caveau du karkabou ce qui tenait ses
assises sous la direction d'étudiants en
droit et ancien étudiant en droit jean
prat staut il est vrai qu'un caveau
d'étudiants en droit ne peut tenir que
ces assisses elle a exactement mais il
est vrai aussi que le derrière ça veut
de l'histoire de bistrot sur la montagne
[Musique]
autant les vous mademoiselle dans
l'ombre chanter les violents écoutez
c'est la ritournelle que tout à l'heure
nous valseront le pied léger petite
foule suivait suivez le tourbillon valse
polka ou farandole à la lumière des
lampions marquer le rythme la cadence et
laissez-moi vous entraîner voyez toute
la ville dense entre ces quatre mardi la
lumière d'août après la période de carca
mousse
le choix est fait chansonnier homme de
spectacle voilà humoriste et je débute
très vite sous l'égide de marie carrier
qui me présente au petit théâtre de la
rive gauche une tambouille une
parenthèse sur la famille a pas eu une
grosse déception ce garçon dont on en
espérait faire un ambassadeur peut-être
même un commissaire de la république
chantal or non un petit peu pendant
quelques semaines et puis quand comme on
a vu que ça marchait bien on l'a dit oui
c'est vrai oui oui c'est tellement plus
amusant qu'est ce qu'il aurait pu faire
donc la famille à tout celui de marché à
accepter ça c'est envisage de le dire
alors l'homme que vous êtes devenu un
homme de spectacle est un homme d'abord
qui serait en cause tous les soirs il
n'a plus de diplômes ne vaut plus rien
le passé ne compte pas chaque jour on se
remet en cause et ensuite c'est un homme
provoquant l'homme qui chansonnier est
un provocateur
oui même sous la forme que j'avais
choisie qui n'était pas une forme tout à
fait conventionnelle c'était pas le
chansonnier et 6 étaient le chansonnier
pasticheur et je pense que ma façon de
pasticher c'était une façon de donner
des coups de pattes
le film publicitaire musique elizabeth
qu'avez-vous elisabeth ce soit vous me
paraissez toute chose
raymond je dirais que je faisais
si je savais ce que c'est que des mets
au fond sur une banquette un jeune homme
triste et boutonneux se pose cette
question comment fait-il pour réussir
comment fait-il pour plaire aux femmes
il plaît aux femmes il plaît aux femmes
parce qu'il a de l'argent et y est vous
aussi de l'argent vous pourrez acheter
une voiture une vertu une conduite des
décorations avec ben l'argent il vous en
faut monsieur il vous en fourbe adam
mais attention exiger la signature n'a
souhaité que le véritable argent de la
prog france le gros paquet 100 francs en
vos atouts non non je pense le
chansonnier genre je pense à lui
comment la plupart des chansonniers mais
en particulier je pense à noël noël avec
une grande reconnaissance aussi sage
c'est vraiment vous tombez bien georges
parce que c'est un homme qui marche qui
m'a aidé à mes débuts et à qui je porte
beaucoup d'admiration de reconnaissance
car c'est un petit peu mousser le
molière de notre profession ses chansons
les retrouve 30 40 ans 50 ans après
elles n'ont pas saisi ou alors ils ont
vieilli comme le misanthrope
je voudrais lui dire qu'il n'a pas
vieilli non plus je sais qu'il est votre
voisin qui ne sort plus beaucoup de chez
lui qui regarde de temps en temps la
télévision et si par aventure il était
devant l'écran de fr3 ce soir j'aurais
l'impression modestement d'être
l'interprète de tout le monde en disant
merci à noël noël 6 heures du matin
macherio tu m'as demandé un article
vaches sur bernard la valette qui
cherchait ses défauts tout de la nuit
rien trouvé son saunier xl en imitateur
parfait auteur comique marrant tragédie
un poignant qu'est ce que tu fous tarik
à se coucher s'embrassent noël mail
[Musique]
regardez bien cette maison des êtres
comme une prison et les led
mais c'est celle de mon enfance j'ai
déjà le blond ferai ma voix a bien moins
changé comme moi
devant le temps je m'aperçois qu'elle a
montré plus dur durant cette coupe a vu
tout petits avec un gros noeud rose ici
des cheveux blonds en boucleront la
boucle et non répand dans les cheveux
pour maintenant ça vaut peut-être mieux
tout l'escalier près du compteur l'a
souvent je joue au docteur avec la figue
percepteur je n'ai bien sûr sans idées
malignes
je suis innocent qui consistait à le
sculpter celui tâtait les mollets puis
lui tapoter gravement le dos la prêtrise
d'areva dans un salon je les revues et
cheveux blancs charme fou des ultimes en
saut là seulement plein de déférence
je pensais du fond de mon cas j'aurais
bien encore de la part mais ça me
rappelle bernard aller qu'ils étaient 80
ans silence d'entente tentant silence
assez du jazz ça se bichonne et moi
c'est tous les acrobates et pourquoi ces
lieux est ce lié à bernard rien parce
qu'ils avaient des sketches qu'il a
toujours d'ailleurs et qui étaient des
skate qui nous enchante et qui affronte
même ma petite fille parce que je lui
racontais et puis elle a entendu
enregistrer les sketches de bernard elle
connaît bernard valette qui est un grand
ami parce que il l'ami de toujours il
est le type on n'a même pas besoin de
demander il est là 11 y aura bien besoin
de quelqu'un c'est bernard il est
merveilleux parce que il est comédien
il travaille avec des chants seigner il
invente ses sketches et c
ses textes et ses musiques enfin et puis
en même temps idées à coeur et je crois
que c'est très important
bernard au oui alors on va voir l'âge
sur lausanne avec tout ça on va les
jantes et freddie vous allez gu ge va
c'est parce que je chante jamais tout
seul parce que si je me sentais tout
seul je pourrais pas chanter c'est que
j'ai besoin des autres
[Musique]
une rue qui monte zigzag
un petit café tout là haut juste à côté
du terrain vague fut assassiné piot se
faisait louche à la nuit noire
ce bistrot au fond d'un jardin on s'en
fichait on veut les boires et le patron
chantait si bien frais des jeux mois sur
ta guitare
la vieille chanson que tu sais mais oui
frais dès la belle histoire où l'on
n'oublie pas le passé aidé et je
m'assure ta guitare
l'histoire où l'on sait
me toulouse ce soir je me sens le coeur
lourd j'ai besoin de chansons d'amour
emmenez là toujours les mêmes faits une
banda s'est mélangé fou il y avait dix
rapin des bohèmes des filles des gars du
quartier enchantait la nuit tout entière
et ans vivait pas mal aussi
la vie nous semblait moins amère et
frais d faisait crédit et des jeux mois
sur ta guitare la vieille chanson que tu
sais mais oui frais dès la belle
histoire
l'on n'oublie pas le passé fait des jeux
mois sur ta guitare l'histoire où l'on
s'aime toujours ce soir je me sens le
coeur lourd j'ai besoin de chansons
d'amour
e
c'est loin et je revois si blanche ta
barbe à travers la fumée et envisage qui
se mange on dirait que tu vas chanter
une douce émotions mot presse je suis en
trad
[Musique]
tous mes souvenirs de jeunesse sont
mêlés à ton nom frais des frais des
odeurs que ta guitare et la chanson que
jamais temps lorsque j'avais les idées
noires
ça m'arrive est bien souvent frais d
l'existence c'est bizarre
beaucoup de ceux que j'aime et sont loin
bien loin dans
le pass ressent dans mes 20 ans fred et
[Musique]
les confidences d'arsène lupin
oui tous les ans je relis un lupin parce
que mon grand-père mot réussite de
fleury était très ami avec maurice
leblanc le père d'arsène lupin et
maurice maeterlinck qui se réunissent et
ils s'appellent eux-mêmes les trois
maurice alors j'ai eu deux virus
personne dupe très très jeune grâce à
mon père et mes enfants sont adoptés
aussi et tous les enjeux reliés un
volume 2 les aventures extraordinaires
d'arsène lupin
un rôle que j'aurai bien aimé jouer au
théâtre
mais il ya quand même le grand parent
peut être chancelier toute sa vie n'est
jamais comédien comment passer de la
deûle à cette réalité du chansonnier à
la fiction du comédien passé le théâtre
qui m'a tendu la main vous cherchez pas
ce que l'on pense et je correspondais un
personnage d'une pièce du comté décrire
bon mais je crois que c'était difficile
pour moi c'était j'étais habitué par le
cabaret par le thé le tour de chant à
parler directement aux périls comme si
c'était une personne alors qu'il fallut
que je casse tout ça pour apprendre à
répondre à mon partenaire avec le texte
d'un autre ce qui m'était plus difficile
d'ailleurs le public n'est pas la sphère
du comédien s'il va faire des
administrateurs et quelques failles à la
pâte
mais on joue pareil que joue la pièce
devant une salle vide
c'est à dire que le d'epernon que vous
êtes à l'origine et a étaient
susceptibles et a prouvé qu'il était
capable de devenir un personnage tout à
fait opposés non pas un zorro comme vous
avez dit mais un personnage complètement
flou un personnage timide des
personnages un peu inconsistant 1-1
marie anne marie un mari que la personne
est la définition du mari que se donner
en retrait parce que c'est une pièce
dans ce grand père le médecin nous
parlions était un ami des grands
comédiens de son temps
surtout lucien guitry et sacha guitry
par ricochet j'ai un très beau livre de
sacha guitry sur son père mon père
lucien guitry dédicacé à mon père c'est
un quatrain que sacha pris la peine de
décrire des demandes et quelques jours
pour le faire et sa page et la peine
puisque ce quatrain dit chacun à sa
manière il avait du génie et comme il
avait tant d'amitié l'un pour l'autre
nous voilà à tous deux réunis vous
pensant à mon père et moi croissante aux
vôtres c'est très joli mais malloy de
journalistes a retenu que le grand-père
neurologue avait des liens amicaux et
peut-être aussi professionnel avec
lucien guitry et qu'est ce qui se
passait à mon dieu je ne sais pas quel
était le secret système nerveux donné du
sien et littré effectivement secret
professionnel mais je pense que tous les
grands artistes sont un petit peu
sensible et ont besoin d'un petit
contrôle médical de temps en temps sans
des vents clients quand le rôle là je
crois sakho 4
je vais pas me priver
il vous plait comment les sous le casque
quel casque ailé sous le casque qu'elle
casse chaque fois faire urgent non je
prends du français si bien c'est sa
faute on voulait lui faire là la
commission vous pouvez vous dire à
madame présent que son frère et lui ai
demandé où il se trouvait un jour de son
mariage il ya 17 ans
mais la liberté du chansonnier comme
celle du journaliste et l'impertinence
et s'il en a pas cette qualité on peut
être ni journaliste ni chansonnier je
crois que je crois vous mêmes
journalistes
si on n'est pas parti dans les palais où
je vais être impertinent
oui la liberté c'est la partie
[Musique]